ce jeudi le parlement européen s'est
réuni de façon exceptionnelle pour agir
dans la crise du coronavirus c'était
dans des conditions particulières
puisque là pratiquement la totalité des
députés européens sont consignés à
domicile et donc nous avons tenu cette
session à distance et nous avons voté à
distance mais surtout nous avons voté
pour une action très importante qui est
le déblocage d'urgence de 37 milliards
d'euros
ces 37 milliards d'euros ils proviennent
des fonds de cohésion des fameux fonds
européens qui n'avaient pas été
utilisées donc par ce vote
ils vont pouvoir rester fléchi dans le
vert les états auxquels ils avaient été
attribués et donc en france les régions
vont pouvoir garder les fonds qui leur
avait été alloué pour prendre des
mesures d'adaptation à la crise alors
ces mesures elles peuvent être très
diverses c'est par exemple soutenir
l'adaptation la transformation d'une
chaîne de production pour produire du
matériel médical exemple une usine qui
produit du parfum ou bien des spiritueux
qui peut s'adapter pour concevoir du gel
hydroalcoolique
c'est aussi dans la même veine de la
production de matériel médical c'est
aussi bien sûr du soutien dans des
entreprises en difficulté ou bien
injecter de l'argent dans les transports
pour par exemple s'adapter et venir en
aide à nos soignants
nous députés européens nous continuons à
travailler sur les mesures à prendre sur
le moyen et court terme puisque cette
crise elle a révélé un grand besoin de
solidarité et surtout d'autonomie en
matière de santé et en matière médicale
alors on peut quand même se féliciter
que la solidarité européenne existe et
qu'elle ait déjà joué à plein je veux
prendre l'exemple des très importants
des hôpitaux de d'allemagne qui ont
accueilli des malades du grand test
c'est aussi la france qui a envoyé du
matériel médical en italie voilà toutes
ses actions elle montre que l'europe est
là et qu'elle est au rendez-vous de
cette crise et qu'elle devra se
renforcer à l'avenir pour lutter sur le
front de la santé